aviones de 14 países distintos ante la
alianza van a empezar a hacer estas
maniobras estos ejercicios de disuasión
nuclear unos ejercicios como que
entrabas que ya se hacen todos los años
ya han empezado hoy mismo y van a durar
hasta el próximo 30 de octubre durante
todos estos días los aviones van a
empezar Ya a sobre bailar Bélgica donde
recordemos está la sede de la otan pero
también el mar del Norte y Reino Unido
estos ejercicios se hacen todos los años
al margen de lo que pueda ocurrir en la
actualidad internacional pero sí que es
cierto que se produce en un top contexto
muy diferente al de hace un año en un
momento en que ha habido amenazas
veladas por parte de Rusia de que
utilizará armas nucleares en la guerra
en Ucrania y tal y como ha precisado la
otan en cualquier en cualquier caso
estos ejercicios siempre son de
preparación ante cualquier eventualidad
y no se van a utilizar en ningún caso
armas reales además estos ejercicios se
producen a más de 1000 kilómetros de la
frontera rusa y además
también del conflicto en Ucrania para
evitar cualquier malentendido Esther
también para hoy se espera una serie
anuncios por parte de los ministros de
exteriores del bloque que es lo que se
va a decidir
Sí así es una agenda muy cargada la de
los ministros de exteriores hoy se
espera que haya sanciones para 11
individuos y cuatro entidades iraníes
por la represión que se ha producido en
el último mes a causa de las protestas
por la muerte de marxa a Mimi se trae
entre los individuos que puede haber
sancionados por ejemplo hay miembros de
la conocida como policía de la moral
además evidentemente la guerra en
Ucrania también marca esta agenda los
ministros de exteriores ya han aprobado
500 millones de euros más para el envío
de armas para Ucrania lo que hace un
monto total de más de 3000 millones de
euros además también se ha probado una
misión de entrenamiento para 15.000
soldados ucranianos en territorio
comunitario una misión de entrenamiento
que se espera que pueda empezar el
próximo noviembre y es muy parecido a la
que han hecho otros países de forma
bilateral para entrenar y para saber
cómo funcionan las armas europeas por
ejemplo ya la han hecho Estados Unidos O
también Alemania y finalmente los
ministros de exteriores también en medio
del congreso del partido comunista en
China van a hablar también de las
relaciones con el gigante asiático van a
abordar las relaciones sobre todo de
China como sociópata también como rival
sistémico